I think you have to do a really in-depth
examination of everything that happened
here if you do things that you wouldn't
do the next time my name is Raymond
Kelly the New York City Police
Commissioner for the last 12 years you
want to tell the public and you also
want to tell the family how the deceased
lost his life the number of bullets that
were fired a chronology of events as you
know them and ideally you get that
information as quickly as possible
whether or not this type of equipment
should actually go down to a small town
level is I think a legitimate question
my own view is that this equipment
should be stockpiled at the state level
and only distributed on as needed basis
both stunning that city or town
population two-thirds african-american
have only three out of 53 police offices
up in african-american both cities and
towns or more proactive in making
certain that their department better
reflects the population of deserving so
a major effort will have to be engaged
in to try to diversify the police force